[Music]
Demonte you guys just tucked down TSM
and qualified for worlds and it wasn't
just a normal series you pulled off the
reverses sweep so just tell me what's
going on in your head right now I mean
holy [ __ ]
clutch gaming weren't supposed to make
worlds they weren't supposed to almost
beat the best team in their league and
playoffs help
they weren't even supposed to be in the
playoffs mark TSM 31 we'll get into it
we will we will thank you for that
promise mark clutch finished the spring
split in ninth place with only one win
separating them from the team in dead
last and the gap between clutch and the
rest of the league was massive so when
clutch began there a long summer climb
to Worlds no one expected much but they
defied the odds continues diving for but
he may have gone a little bit too far
he's taken into the guardian angel the
resurrection comes through bone and
Guardians tilting to grab themselves to
kill FB i--'s throw the spears and
there's a kill for froggen FB I've taken
down though and the golden Guardians are
finding themselves on the wrong into the
fight they gave us one of the greatest
cinderella stories the LCS has ever seen
but then their legend was cut short
because clutch blew up before they ever
got a chance to run it back
your final representative
before world's 2019 if you knew anything
about clutch gaming you knew them as
that team that made a playoffs in their
first ever split in the LCS it's one for
one so far support can be traded off
[Applause]
[Applause]
finals watch gaming will be the first
organization to deny them their pass to
the cities in Miami but after that
clutch took a nosedive finishing their
next two splits in ninth so how did they
go from a complete mess with no domestic
hopes to a world's contender well they
have to change everything to do it
Dignitas and clutch gaming are emerging
so essentially we now will be helping
run and operate that LCS team so clutch
was in the toilet by the end of the 2019
spring split but shockingly Dignitas
were still interested in picking up the
team so they took over operations and
started cleaning things up
I mean Dignitas came in the biggest
change I came with it was the person who
was running the team and Michael
printable is like the CEO of dignitas
and he kind of came in right away and
made sure that everyone knew that kind
of used the boss now and when he did
that he can't establish a new culture at
the team and it kind of unified us all
from just like this group of five
players that all of us knew we were good
individually into this group of five
players were like we all wanted to be a
team suddenly eventually clutch would
become Dignitas but even before that the
new CEO and GM knew that the team could
go far Michael came in you know he met
everyone tried to find out what was
going on why was his team losing he did
a lot of you know sitting back just
observing and you know finally it came
down to you know after rift rivals me
and him sat down you know what what
needs to change with this team to make
them winners because it's very obvious
on paper this team is extremely good you
know we properly explained Mike you know
this team ceiling is as high as second
place and they made changes to clutch as
coach
staff to the big change is made were
obviously the removal of our former head
coach and then one of our assistant
coaches as well we ended up bringing on
Fink card he's done phenomenal highly
valued coach you know with his game
since you know can really appreciate
what he brings to the table and while
that doesn't seem like much had a solid
roster ready to go first was hooni
always loud always cocky I think right
now my skills the level is like the only
impact can match person my skills what
do you think about Kobe as a caster do
you have any opinions on Kobe as a
caster yes
whatever his grade is great I love him
about summer as individually as also
like in only LCS like Allison ten out of
ten I think I perform like really well I
was I really said about how how I was
doing it really real well the montane
returned to the starting lineup after a
short trip to the bench and became a
meme hugger not do you know what time it
is I know
do you know can you save me the same
time yeah all right three two one time
but it wasn't all means clutch also had
the quieter Lehrer in the jungle Vulcan
a young French Canadian support and the
ever consistent ad carry Cody son you
know what they say you cry when you
what are you hush spend most of the
summer in the middle of the pack they
always beat teams below them in the
standings but they never could quite
beat the ones above them clutch wanted
the playoffs as the 5th seed which meant
they were surrounded by teams they
couldn't beat so it's no surprise that
nobody expected clutch to even win their
first match dad what do you got I have
gsm more so because clutches 9 and oh
sorry one in nine against playoff teams
and 8 no against non-playoff teams and
their plight of less are in the playoff
alright so yeah but on game day clutch
prove everyone wrong no zero there's the
pull for round two again dismounting
broken blade bps falling go to Cody Sun
didn't respect Bullas ok tahm Kench
cover knock up those two the four versus
three right now he just read it for a
bit more nice down in the book and here
comes Lera now as well four versus four
at the residence bond comes in
especially all if he is having a good he
clarifies who's babe Bravo builds a lot
as well
look at the team fight
bjergsen's gone for clutch TSM can win
any a fight but it's always a noun
excuse you know flag on the floor equals
over the top gonna get a lotta damage of
the speak at a stop by fight even more
time to panic down in the back fed is
dangerous
for it the push in the ice and what a
teamfight whoo what a game what a series
clutch daming three two one
knockdown TSM but even though clutch
beat TSM there were still doubters TSM
was in shambles at the time running a
rookie jungler who just debuted two
weeks earlier so their next series was
clutch as a real test they were up
against the defending champions the best
team na had ever seen Team Liquid people
were expecting a three of all right mark
your Clell now it's too late
yeah 3o thirty in a handshake 3o thirty
in a handshake they were expecting
clutch to put up a fight yeah but x50
wants to make them pay for it Oh
three-man team liquid flank of an
intimacy with the flash we're gonna keep
himself alive to make the trade come out
clutch gaming will collapse Team Liquid
still not 1v1 you're gonna win up
against Jensen counter-attack to me now
as Vulcan goes in with the Nautilus
Demonte gonna be soaking some damage and
Vulcan is gone
delante is gone a double kill for impact
and Team Liquid are all in this victory
march Jensen's on the rampage impact got
a triple kill and hudie watches on and
the rest of clutch Falls to help a lot
in flush laying or all three of those
but now we're going in and double it's
gonna be the target for Jay Jay keeps
them alive before
[Applause]
honestly about the Tim Lucas series was
like really really close I was like
really sad after because I think we
could have easily make it we could have
done it and it was like damn if you want
if he just want more game like we've got
this one with the final I mean after the
series is over I think that's been
always realized that we can actually go
to Worlds and I this year actually could
end with us being in like a different
continent
I want everyone what do you think about
how badly did one of the world's I badly
want to [ __ ] win I do not want to
play in Sochi I guess my quest isn't and
move these [ __ ] teams and not better
than that we use it to be a world we
need to try [ __ ] harder fly Quest CLG
TSM if clutch wanted to go to Worlds and
they did they had to beat each one of
these teams in the gauntlet one by one
clutch gave me in four games is going to
look to find their first regional
qualifier victory and they're going to
be doing it against
quest and go on to face counter logic
gaming weekly up in six dirt they have
the mountain dream I prefer that going
[Applause]
play DSM for the lost spot at Worlds
clutch ran through fly class hen CLG
beating both teams three two one but TSM
proved to be their true challenge when
you is not a peaceful people it's not
going to be like for sure easy because
at same time TSM was like mad that we be
done and that we were like hell up
practicing it a lot a lot alive
I mean Joseph has got to be careful
demotic still has his flash and is
ultimate year and they are kind of
playing with fire it feels like that's
gonna be one down Lyra it goes down
who's gonna be getting the red pickup
for TSM they're gonna start trying to
take down to Mont a chase him down to
the wrap to fit its Cody Sun has to
feather storm out of this one
it's he SF come up you and they
absolutely melt flush game a one in the
regional qualifier of finals going to
TSM s they want revenge over clutch
gaming stasis now from the guardian
angel to come up for Demonte what can he
do before he goes down and it's gonna be
up to spend now to the man
[Applause]
we're going on the game three because in
victory 40 these games after just came
one even though we kind of lose like I
feel like they're playing so bad and
especially like there was a lot big copy
after like I was like really confident
that I can beat this guy like five games
in an hour and I told to my teammates
just like it's gonna go five games no
matter what after two games like just
play until we lose one more Nexus and I
was like we can't lose this shitty team
like we cancel that yes I'm go to like
Wars goes very bad you know what are you
playing outside a blue hoodie flanking
now I spent is down rested TSM has to
find their way in through their own
front door cuz they can talk face to the
fountain
that's an ultimate stolen only Vanguard
death to Pearson isn't gonna really do
too much against clutch they are now
inside the base booty is a bot their
solos fed with sejuani right next to of
diving it on the Orillia and cool
Jack's still available to use his
Pearson's look at the Kayla Mooney
so is this for who he just gets to drop
out that's gonna be the barela's last
ignite so he stays alive here comes to
Ma takers they still prison in his hands
for gonna go one kill there and he uses
it to take down the rest of G at SAP TSM
on the iron one per game
[Applause]
point but now it's gonna be for both
teams
clutch kami come all the way back like I
said they planted the seed for the
reverse sweep and man as it's starting
to grow as they may stay for the final
touches the best
the first Nexus turn is going in
clutches I a second year together for
your final representative watch gaming
in the end clutch played 27 postseason
games more games and they played the
entire regular season they battled with
kings they tasted defeat in front of
tens of thousands of fans and they
pulled off an insane reverse sweep
against one of North America's most
beloved teams in the end clutch we're
going to Worlds yeah we knew we were
gonna Road it was super cereal because I
think this is it this is 20 19 years it
was this big grind for all the players
on our team and there were ups and downs
and then for all that to lead up taxi I
was going to world it's like wow like
this is what I've been wanting all my
career and my career has not even been
that long I've already made it here
clutches world's run was less than
stellar weights before moving towards
excretes it's SKT go undefeated in the
first half of groups and make a
statement it's the base camp give it to
us but no it doesn't matter of kids a
hold on there's just too much damage the
tip where it's not enough from Kody son
I don't think they can do with the
towers they've broken down the Nexus has
been taking down a clutch but at all
use everything in the process RNG will
eliminate clutch to make thing go zero
five they're not done just yet a couple
extra kills before the Nexus falls honey
will be blown up already set their
sights on fanatics and a little bit more
of a methodical game out of IRG while
they made it out of the play in stage
they got stuck with a group of death
against three of the best teams in the
world so they lost like a lot but who
could blame them a new format to go zero
in fixing groups it's a clear nobody had
as ridiculous a group is not all 2020 it
looked bright for this clutch gaming
roster they made it to world off the
back of a Cinderella run that captivated
fans Kody Demonte and Vulcan the world
relatively young burgeoning and a
talents the team was gonna be called
Dignitas now but that hardly mattered
they would still be able to keep the
fans enthralled but before the roster
could run it back in the new decade it
collapsed the off season started and
Lyra Demonte Cody Sun and Vulcan along
with coach Artemis were out even their
GM left to join evil geniuses the only
player left from the team that shook up
na still on Dignitas was Moony the party
was over
well Vulcan and Cody Sun landed on their
feet Lyra and the monta weren't as lucky
Demond - can you say what you are doing
next split next but um I mean eyes of
right now it looks like I'm probably
gonna be playing in Academy the collapse
of clutch gaming Rob North America of
one of the most interesting teams the
league has seen in years
they weren't a super team like Team
Liquid or legacy fan favorites like TSM
and c9 they were something brand new a
team of upstarts who did the impossible
clutch climbed out of the gutter to the
top of Na forcing fans to give them the
respect they deserved and fans fell in
love with them both for their hilarious
personalities and their underdog story
but now we'll never know what could have
been
we'll never know what that incredible
roster could have done with another year
of support could they make it to finals
could they topple Team Liquid could they
make it out of groups
world's and that's the true tragedy of
clutch gaming we'll never know just how
far they could have gone I'd be careful
with how you say cocky so you don't just
say cocky and then it just on the [ __ ]
pokie pokie that's gonna get turned to
an end bored I'm so [ __ ] why did I do
that okay like a [ __ ] cliff keeper
Matt